Good morning Hank.
It's Tuesday.
So yesterday some friends and I went to the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway, and I got to
drive around the track with race car driver
Sarah Fisher at 180 miles per hour and experience
profound fear-joy, which would be a good name
for a band.
But for now the relevant thing is while I
was going around the track I felt like Sarah
Fisher was driving the Batmobile and I was
Robin.
And that reminded me that while I'm a big
Sarah Fisher fan, I kind of hate Batman.
Like Hank, if I were a billionaire, the first
thing I would do would be to pledge 90% of
my money to charity.
Then I would build my own race track that
Sarah Fisher could drive me around, then I
would give AFC Wimbledon a bunch of money
so they could build a new stadium.
Then I'd build a huge house with lots of secret
rooms that you can only access by touching
certain books on a fake bookshelf, and then
I would still be SUPER rich because a billion
dollars is a lot of money...
but I am getting slightly off topic here.
The point being, Hank, I don't think I'd be
a particularly good or generous billionaire,
but one thing I wouldn't do is spend a gajillion
dollars developing a Batmobile that only I
am allowed to drive.
I mean look Hank, Spiderman go bit by a radioactive
spider; he has to be Spiderman; he doesn't
have a choice; he can't stop shooting webs
so you might as well use that skill to aid
the police.
Similarly, Sailor Moon didn't choose to be
an alien princess from Silver Millennium,
but Batman is just a rich guy with an affinity
for bats who's playing out his insane fantasy
of single handedly ridding Gotham of crime;
how is that heroic?
Now I know what you're saying Hank- Iron Man-
and fair enough, Tony Stark is a billionaire
who could use his wealth a little bit better.
And that's a story unto itself about how the
superheroes elevated by each generation say
a lot about that generation.
But at least Iron Man has that weird nuclear
bomb heart thing built with the help of the
token good, and therefore doomed Arab guy.
And then he's like "Aw I should use my nuclear
heart for good."
It's not much but it's something.
Meanwhile can you really argue that Batman
is good for Gotham?
I mean in the Batman universe crime is caused
by:
1.
Evil people who just wanna see the world burn
and
2.
Stupid people who follow the evil but charismatic
cat person/joker/penguin.
God, the villains in Batman are terrible.
Also, slightly off topic but I would argue
that Catwoman despite her jewelry thieving
etc. is by almost any measure much more heroic
than Batman.
But anyway, crime is not actually caused by
evil; it's caused by systemic disenfranchisement
and poverty and lack of access to job opportunities
and education.
And yet Batman continues on, not funding police
departments or schools or building low income
housing, but tearing up the infrastructure
of the city he claims to love while fighting
villains who are only powerful because that
city is already so blighted and dysfunctional.
I'm sorry I'm losing my temper, but does Batman
understand how difficult it is for an under-funded
city like Gotham to replace roads and bridges?
Anyway Hank, it seems to me that one of the
more realistic facets of the Batman saga is
that Gotham never gets better for long after
Batman's villain-destroying exploits.
Batman saves Gotham over and over and over
again, but he never actually improves it.
Also, why does no one ever call Batman out
for devoting all of his resources to fighting
crime in Gotham?
When he could also be fighting, I don't know,
global poverty or habitat destruction or climate
change.
Now Hank I'm not saying that cleaning up the
streets of Gotham isn't a worthy goal for
a billionaire, but to reiterate, he's bad
at it.
I will say this, Hank, Batman has inspired
some great graphic novels and some very good
movies.
All of which go to extraordinary lengths to
make it seem like bad things just keep happening
to Batman, so he has to develop a massive
arsenal that he keeps in a Batcave.
But Hank, the question at the core of the
Batman story still bothers me.
Why do we celebrate the vigilantic ambitions
of individual billionaires?
Surely we understand that the real work among
humans is done not in isolation but in collaboration?
We do understand that, right?
And no I am not just saying all of this because
my hair looks more and more like Wolverine's
by the day.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.